dea
今から日本語のレッスンを行います
日本語アドバイス第2回開始日本語を勉強していて何か恥ずかしい思いをしたことが
ありますか
あるある授業で友達と一緒に他動詞と自動詞を勉強していたら間違えてウンチをもらっ
ちゃった
ケアレスミスとや使うこと
このシートつそして運塗装の違いを見破るのに時間がかかります区別をつける方法って
ありますか
かなり大変だけどはトーキョーグールを見るのやめて20分以上を勉強すること好きな
文法ってありますか
基本的に運文の文法だったら結構好きでそれを勉強すればいう文の勉強がいかに無駄で
あるか分かるようになり時間をもっと大切
にするようになるからだじゃなくて何何しながらが日本語の勉強部頑張りましょう自分
はネットで若者とよく話していて自分の日本語がリンカーンパークぽくなってるんじゃ
ないかって心配していますとしたらいいですか
お医者さんに診てもらった方がいいねできれば皮膚科道元らしい言葉を何ですか
教養
もしくはインパ日本は独特の季節が4つもあるって聞きましたが事実ですか
信じがたい話だが事実だここで覚えるというえ
花粉症夏バテ稼ぎみゆフルエンザいわゆる
春固執秒アメリカに帰った時に恋しくなる日本ってありますか
社会主義兵士のみなさーんそれと豚骨ラーメン先輩も
後輩もいるときどのぐらい丁寧に話したらいいですか
僕の大学の先生たちと同じことをすればいい先生 a は51歳だったんだけど大学で
を1年間しか働いていなかった
先生美本45歳だったんだけど大学では10年も働いていた
さあ先生達を何をしてたんだろうそう英語で話していた
チケットなしでアイドルのイベントに入ろうとし
たぶん何も話を聞いてもらえませんでした
何かアドバイスはありますか会場の裏に入ってイベントが終わるのを待ってください
自分の会いたいアイドルを廊下で習えばいい
tame ni
ni